[Music]
Japan has made amazing progress in the last quarter of a century.
The dream of participating in the soccer World Cup has come true, and
that role
has already been fulfilled.
Do you have the courage to dream of a new dream of winning the World Cup?
To make that new dream come true
, create the world's number one striker.
So congratulations on my stupid dream of
one day becoming the ace striker of the Japan national team and
winning the World Cup
.
Let's live only for that moment
That
's the striker, isn't it?
I
don't want it to end This isn't the soccer anime I've seen so far I
'll show you the evolution and awakening of the passionate egoists with my own
eyes I'll be the one who
survives
Blue Rock Broadcast on Saturday, October 8th in the
Numa animation frame of TV Asahi's nationwide network  start